and one of the things that the BBC the
organizer said at the beginning
is that you know this is about saving
ourselves our our economic models
because we are you know most people look
at us and they say
CNN and BBC are competitors but we
aren't the real competition is coming
from these thousands of emerging
alternative media sites that are eroding
Trust
in the in the Legacy sites and are
taking away our our business model
and we need to bond together
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
an environmental lawyer author and
candidate for president of the United
States Robert F Kennedy Jr finally
welcome to the Reuben report Dave thanks
for having me sorry it took me so long
no I'm glad to have you and uh with all
the media stuff you've been going
through over the last couple weeks
you've given us plenty to talk about
first off though you usually do these
interviews sitting in your library am I
getting the uh the special office
interview or what's going on here I'm in
a hotel room in New York City
Hotel in New York I'll take it all right
so let's dive into it I thought before
we get into some of the specifics uh and
all the media stuff that's been
happening and everything else
um I was once a Democrat and when we
talk about you on my show people often
ask uh Dave what makes RFK a Democrat at
this point this isn't 1960 1970 1980. so
I guess that's my first question to you
what what sort of lines you up with the
modern Democrat Party at this point
well I don't
um I I my my uh loyalty and affiliation
affinity for the Democratic Party
um is you know for the party that I grew
up with and I I think you know what's
happening at the party today is
unfortunate I do think the party I do
believe the party is redeemable
ultimately
um
so uh and I think our country is
redeemable and I think we need both of
those things to happen you know if you
go if you went through a checklist Dave
of all of the things that my uh my uncle
John Kennedy My Father Robert Kennedy
believed in and Edward Kennedy believed
and you would I would kind of check
probably every item on the list
um
whereas today you know some of the
issues that the Democratic party has
embraced are things that I'm
uncomfortable with and I think a lot of
people around the country are and a lot
of the traditional base
of the democratic party which was
working people's unions American middle
class
um and now more and more
uh minorities uh blacks and Hispanics
are moving away from the Democratic
party because they feel like they've
been neglected and that the party is not
representing their
um their interests anymore or their
value
what do you think the best way to sort
of separate what I would consider the
old school classical liberals guys like
you and and your uncle and your father
uh from what's going on with with the
more radical Progressive branch
well you know I just talk I I try not to
talk uh
about you know I I try not to bad mouth
anybody you know I I think there's been
enough of that in this country and
people are are done with it
and we need to find a path back to
civility
and to end this very very toxic
polarization so I try not to you know
condemn other people and I just I talk
about the things that I believe in which
are the Traditional Values the
Democratic party I try to find I'm uh
and I've always done this
try to identify the values that we have
in common rather than focusing on the
um the issues that hold us apart you
know I I spent
35 years as a as kind of with one of the
leading environmental champions in this
country but I was speaking
regularly probably doing 60 big speeches
a year to mainly Republican groups and I
was getting outstanding Ovations and
most of them because I didn't focus on
the issues
there's no such thing as Republican
children or Democratic children we all
want a clean environment
had become a very partisan issue so I
tried to talk about the environment in a
way
that you know that every American could
Embrace and I I think most of us 80 of
us
agree on on 99 of the issues
yeah have you been shocked at the way
the media has been treating you because
you've been out there basically talking
to everybody having open conversations
you're talking to people on the right
you're talking to people on the left and
the media has gone after you in an
absolutely crazy way I want to read one
headline to you it's about your wife who
I adore and we were sort of in similar
circles when I lived in LA and I love
curb but this headline that I'm sure you
saw from The New York Times Cheryl Hines
the Curb Your Enthusiasm actress is
beloved in Hollywood now she's
supporting the presidential campaign of
her husband Robert F Kennedy Jr is she
normalizing his often dangerous ideas I
actually retweeted it and I asked people
to come up with some of your dangerous
ideas and nobody seems to really know
what they are but that doesn't stop the
New York Times
yeah I know all of my conspiracy
theories as it turns out have come true
oh yeah they're no longer there is there
you know they're now a proven hypotheses
but
you know what I I do wonder about it I
you know I was thinking about this this
morning
that I'm because the the this kind of
this hail storm of negative publicity
about I mean really kind of not
it goes beyond like hit pieces it's to
be just is you know poisonous vitriol
um and that it's coming from all the
Legacy Media from the Atlantic Monthly
from New York Magazine New York or from
the Washington Post and the New York
Times from Vanity Fair
Daily Beast uh Daily Coast
Rolling Stone
and and many many others
and they all kind of use the same
talking points and uh and they also are
not accurate you know none of them has
really written an accurate
and that's one of the reasons it doesn't
trouble me is because it's it's just
it's just inaccuracies distortions
miscarrierizations
um but one of the things that kind of
occurred to me
is that there's something bigger at
player than just their kind of hatred of
me
um that this is It's I feel like I'm
kind of on the spirit tip
of a war between the this declining uh
Legacy Media
and the evolving and emerging a new
media the podcasters the you know all of
these alternative news sites
and I'm in a litigation right now
against an organization called the TNI
The Trusted news initiative
The Trusted news initiative was a I was
a conspiracy
that was initiated by BBC
where they called together all of the
Legacy news sites including API the
American Associated Press Reuters
on the UPI The Washington Post and many
many others and
they married them to the social media
sites to Microsoft to Google Facebook
Twitter and they all made an agreement
with each other that they would censor
certain kinds of information for example
any information about Cove at departed
from government orthodoxies but also
information that challenged any kind of
political orthodoxies like any reports
on a hunter Biden's laptop
reports about the Ukraine war were
inconsistent with the official U.S
positions
and this was an extraordinary thing this
has never happened before
but we've obtained during the litigation
the internal
Communications and one of the things
that the BBC the organizer said at the
beginning
is that you know this is about saving
ourselves our our economic models
because we are you know most people look
at us and they say
CNN and BBC are competitors but we
aren't the real competition is coming
from these thousands of emerging
alternative media sites that are eroding
Trust
in the in the Legacy sites and are
taking away our our business model
and we need to bond together and so the
way it worked was
that they would all identify issues and
identify individuals who were saying
things that should be censored
they would notify each other of those of
those posts or those articles and of
those individuals they would censor them
and then the social media sites would
not allow those the sites that printed
them on so if you were you know a green
Med info this is a you know a site that
provides Wellness information or Joe or
Cola or one of these sites
these others are Breitbart or somebody
who was departing from government
orthodoxies you would find yourself
banned on social media and those sites
absolutely require
social media for their business models
so if they if you prevent them from
going viral although the way their
business model works is they put in
articles they print articles or publish
articles
think of viral
that's the only way that they grow that
they earn you know that they can earn
advertising dollars so if you cut them
off there and this is what the Emma from
BBC said
we need to choke off those sites so they
wanted to kill all those guys
and they did it by agreeing on a single
narrative which was the official
government narrative
and then censoring or ridiculing you
know do it or or throttling or Shadow
Banning
anybody who uh who challenged those
Orthodoxy so you have you know the
Legacy Media which traditionally
wasn't functioning as Guardians of the
first amendment of free expression
they were you know they were supposed to
courageously speak truth about or
maintain this posture of fear of
skepticism towards Big aggregations of
power government corporations and they
now become the opposite they become
propagandists with a powerful and
oppressors of of you know a free speech
and the enemies of the First Amendment
and that you know I find myself I you
know I now see
myself as a spirit tip of this emerging
media which is in an economic
competition but also kind of an
ideological you know Armageddon
with the old media sites and you know so
I'm being championed by Russell Brad and
by Joe Rogan and a you know a Lex
Freeman and all of these you know kind
of
alternative media Giants
uh in a battle and I think they see that
as well Russell Brand said to me
something about that the other day that
sent me thinking is you know of
how they need to uh those sites
really need to understand where we all
are in this where they are in this world
of you know of of disruption of the old
uh of the old business model
right and it's really bizarre because
even now when they've been so frequently
exposed for the censorship your
interview with my friend Jordan Peterson
from about two weeks ago was taken down
on YouTube and then they put it up on
Rumble and now you're on Rumble and
they're not censoring anybody but what
do you think about so what would you do
so so if you were president of the
United States what would you do in terms
of big Tech is it is it breaking them up
is it regulating them how do you connect
that to what you just described with the
Legacy Media that's offering you know
that's usually pushing the pressure on
big Tech to do these things and then of
course the connections we now know with
the CIA and FBI and everything else
yeah well more and more you know we're
beginning to understand and this you
know the judicial decision this week by
judge Dougie and um you know in the
Missouri and Louisiana
uh attorney general's case is on I think
really lays it out at um
that the social media sites were kind of
victims as well
of of the censorship because they were
and I was you know I'm in judged the
decision is 155 pages and it's a
decision that forbids the Biden White
House
I'm having any contact with social media
sites it's this extraordinary injunction
and it's I think it's bulletproof I
think that's why he did this you know
155 page decision because he wanted to
lay out the evidence
and he talks about the history about how
the Biden Administration
I'm initiated this is uh the censorship
uh push
uh Blitzkrieg
um and a I was the first one
that they ordered censored oh the Bible
Administration came into office on
January 21st
2021 on January 23rd they contacted
Facebook the White House contact
Facebook and asked them to start to
remove me and then three weeks later
there was a battle
the the people in the White House were
threatening Facebook
with withdrawal of their section 230
immunity which is existential threat to
them section 230 of course is a the
liability Shield
so that you know if you defamed uh you
know Donald Trump on Facebook and said
something that was untrue that you knew
to be untrue that was scurrilous and
very damaging
he can sue you but he can't sue Facebook
that Facebook is and is supposed to be a
neutral platform and it cannot be suited
and that's called section 230.
Mark Zuckerberg said if we lose that
it's existential we cease to exist and
so right they would actually have to
censor more in that case because they
would have more liability so they'd be
basically censoring everybody well yeah
I mean they would need to read every
they would have to have lawyers read
every single post
and it says it for you know for
defamation there would be no way to do
it it would just collapse so
um so and that's what the White House
was threatening if you don't censor
these guys we're gonna withdraw your
section 230 immunity so
the White House was strong arming them
in the most powerful way a two sensor
and then the White House invited in all
of these agencies the really weird
agencies like the Census Bureau I mean
the CIA was involved the FBI was
involved
the DH had the Department of Homeland
Security was involved
but also like the IRS and uh and the
Census Bureau and a whole bunch of other
agencies were all involved in
identifying people that needed to be
censored and the things they were
censoring were really crazy
you know it's the same thing that TNI
was censoring like 100 Biden's laptop
you weren't allowed to talk about that
anything to do with the Wuhan lab you
couldn't talk about
um but also personal attacks on the
president there was a parody of the
president and his wife
um that uh that they ordered taken down
so this is you know really this is like
King George the third you know back back
in the revolution this is the reason we
had the Revolution was that and put the
first amendment in place so that the the
king or the you know ruler could not
silence critics because if Government
Gonzalez as critics it has license for
any atrocity
so so what would your policy be would it
be that you'd break up some of these
companies or would it be that you'd be
regulating them or let them collapse
what I
um first of all on day one I'm gonna I'm
gonna issue executive orders forbidden
for bidding uh any uh Federal agency
from engaging in the censorship
activities or recommendations or
contacts with these companies regarding
posts that they don't like
there's of course things that should be
removed from the internet you know but
they're they're it's unprotected speech
you know pedophilia and uh um and you
know uh inciting violence and you know
those kind of things you you can censor
without not violating the First
Amendment because they're not we're
friends they're illegal
yeah they're illegal and they're not
protected by the First Amendment
but otherwise I'm going to order them
all not only am I going to order them to
stop censoring
but I'm gonna basically with you know
reinstate the Smith month that month act
which has been effectively just
forgotten about and abandoned that
forbids
um the federal agencies from
propagandizing American people
and that's is just as frightening what's
happening now with you know active
propaganda by the CIA through all of
these legitimate media sites
um of our you know of debates about the
Ukraine war and about things that
Americans should not be propagandized
about you know we should we should know
who you know I think everybody should be
able to talk about these things but we
should know who it is talking
we shouldn't have the CIA running
reporters in the Rolling Stone and uh
daily calls and Daily Beast and telling
us you know pretending that they're
neutral reporters
how worried are you that what Trump
describes as the Swamp or what you're
just you know the CIA the three letter
agencies all the Deep State all of this
stuff that that going against it and
talking about it the way you talk about
it which is somewhat similar to the way
Trump talks about it that it's it's a
machine that is so embedded or as your
uncle used to talk about the the secrecy
cannot be a piece of a flourishing
democracy but it's so embedded in
everything right now all of our agencies
all of our institutions ESG all of these
things that it actually can't change
that much it would you know you can go
in and you can do executive actions and
all that but somehow the system the
swamp just keeps moving forward
yeah I don't believe that I I you know
I'm very excited about having an
opportunity to fit because and I think
I'm uniquely
um positioned to do that because
I've spent 40 years suing these agencies
and thinking about how do you unravel
agency capture and you know I've sued
I've had suits involving almost all of
the major agencies uh Nia CDC FDA HHS
and then the the Department of
Agriculture because I've spent
I spent 20 years suing factory farms and
and you know big processed food
producers I saw how that agency has been
taken over by industrial Agriculture and
you know I was completely drifted away
from its mission of protecting small
family farmers and providing
America wholesome food supply I'm
involved now
with litigation that involves Department
of Transportation on you know and
representing a thousand families and uh
Norfolk Southern spill that you know
I've ended their lives and that spill
happened because of agency capture in
many of these agencies you know and of
course I've
probably 20 percent of the 500
environmental cases that I've been
involved with um haven't fall have been
against EPA
uh you know which is captured by the
pesticide industry by the uh by uh uh
oil and coal industry
when I sit on Santa we came across
emails
um secret emails that Monsanto had
exchange with the head of the pesticide
division a guy called Jess Roland who
was taking a federal paycheck and
supposedly working for the taxpayer but
secretly
he was working for Monsanto and this is
the problem is that most of the people
who work at these agencies are
well-intentioned individuals they're
Patriots they're good government
employees good public servants
but the people who tend to rise to the
top and become the division heads the
branch has
and of course you know the directors of
those departments um are are people who
are in the are in the tank with the
industry mm-hmm and uh and they you know
set the tone and they set the agenda for
the whole so I need to go in there and
and do that you know I I've spent
a lot of my life studying the CIA
because my families uh 60-year fist
fight with that agency I know how my
uncle was going to try to reorganize the
agency if he hadn't been killed
I know exactly what my father was going
to do with the agency in fact he had a
long conversation with it a week before
he died with Peter Hamill is my friend
who's uh you know was a reporter who was
covering him
and I don't think it's a hard thing to
do you need to you know you need to get
rid of the perverse incentives these
Financial entanglements with the the
agencies have with the industries
they're supposed to regulate
you need to move around certain
individuals and and you need to put in
place really good
um uh laws against uh against revolving
doors
which is part of the problem you know
people work for 20 years for the federal
government for one of these agencies and
they're uh and as soon as they're
pension passed
they move over to the industry that
they've been regulating and so they want
a good job and a lot of them are the
heads of departments now
and they end up doing a bunch of favors
for these companies right before they
leave
and in order to get the paybacks and I
can give you example after example of
that but we need you know right now they
just have to wait 12 months we need a
five-year wait uh to make sure to get
rid of those revolving doors
and uh you know but I think it can be
fixed Dave I you know I'm very confident
that's something I'm very very excited
about doing and I'm going to go to the
agencies myself
you know I'm gonna go to Bethesda and
I'm going to go you know to the EPA and
I'm gonna you know
um I'm gonna have direct uh interactions
with those agencies and make sure that
the
and to the state department which is now
run from top to bottom by neocons who
are you know whose job is to keep us
involved in these constant Wars
and we need to move those people out
and uh you know and reinstate
re-install the Integrity in those
agencies and the public purpose
so I sense you have a you see a bit of a
connection between say some of the
coverage that you get in places like the
New York Times and your criticism of uh
the agencies and things like that like
you see this as sort of sort of one
Insidious web which I think is deeply
also connected to the Democrat Party
these days I mean the fact that you're
polling in some places over 20 percent
right now and they are making it very
very clear that they're not going to put
you on a debate stage I mean a lot of
Democrats I think are not happy about
this I know a lot of Republicans are not
happy about it and they're happy to talk
to you
I think yeah I mean I you know I think
you know one one of the things I said
in my um in my speech my announcement
speech in Boston is that the people who
are normally put in charge of these
agencies and and this was what Trump did
too
you know Trump came in and he promised
to to train the swamp and then you know
he put me he named me as head of the
vaccine safety Commission
and I started that function I met with
fauci I met with Collins and was putting
together that you know project and then
uh when that news got out
Pfizer gave a million dollar
contribution to Trump and uh and Trump
appointed to Pfizer's hand-picked
candidates Alex Azar
around HHS and Scott Gottlieb who was a
partner of Pfizer to run FDA and you
know Godly came in there uh in an 88
billion dollar gift to of operation
speed for her for Pfizer and then left
to join Pfizer board and get his
collector's payoff so you know that is
the swamp and and uh you know uh people
come in wanting to change it but they
get intimidated by these big agencies
and they um uh and they you know get
frightened because yeah the agency can
hurt you you know if you go after that
agency
there's a lot of top level officials in
there who can commit all kinds of civil
disobediences that will embarrass the
president and so what they do is they
appoint somebody who's safe they look at
the agency they say I'd like to change
that but I got other agendas
they leave the whole you know instrument
of corruption intact
and they appoint somebody who's safe
and that person you know Ralph Reid once
said to me the guys who get those jobs
are the guys who who get the joke you
know
right right well I said in my
announcement speeches I get the joke but
I don't think it's funny you know right
exactly and I'm not safe no I'm not you
know I'm my job is to keep the American
people safe
but I'm not going to be safe with a
status quo I'm going to be the worst
nightmare for the status quo
so for all the people that hear you the
independence the what I would say are
the remaining sort of old school
liberals and for even some conservatives
who are open to a lot of these ideas and
a lot of the stuff you're talking about
it's it's sort of trumpian in a certain
sense it's stuff that Tucker Carlson
talks about I want to get to the Ukraine
war in a second
um but what would you what's the way to
get you on that stage so that there can
be a debate between you and Joe Biden
because to me the the difference would
be so Stark that that could start the
Avalanche like that seems to be the
chance
what can you do with the Democrat Party
in essence is what I'm asking you know I
think we need to go the Democratic party
and to to into a debate I mean we're
we're at a period in history where you
know so many Americans no longer believe
in the political process they think is
rigged against them and you know the
Democratic party or and the Republican
Party ought to be doing their best
to Showcase gold standard elections
and to tell you know the American people
democracy counts your vote counts your
opinion counts
and we're actually going to do retail
campaigning we're gonna
have to base we're gonna you know we're
not going to be like the Soviet Union
where you know with a party would pick
the candidate and tell you you know
here's who you voted for and there's no
real contest going on and no real choice
this is America we're we you know we
model democracy for the world we should
have a model you know a role model
election in this country and you know
let's
you know we need to tell Joe Biden and
you know to embrace the ideals that he
stood for for his whole career and not
end his career by you know tarring our
country with a with a you know with a
regular action this
the Democrat are you in any contact with
the Democrat Party I mean have you have
they specifically said we're not gonna I
mean I'm guessing they don't pick up
your calls right oh no we're not in
contact with them I mean they've you
know been very clear
if they don't want me in this election I
hear it from people all the time you
know why don't you um you know you can
hurt Joe Biden you know again and get
Trump elected
um you know people say that to me a lot
you know people who are in the party or
uh you know I ran into Hillary Clinton
at a dinner a couple of weeks ago and
she said something like that to me
along those lines
um and you know and it's it's strange
because most
um
I don't think anybody is happy with the
choices that Americans are being given
right now and I think you know we need
some other choices I'm glad Marianne
Williamson is in this race I hope Gavin
Newsom gets into it I think you know we
need choices we need we can't just have
a Kabuki theater you know democracy we
need we need a real you know we're
supposed to be the Democrats supposed to
be the party of the new deal not the
party of the rig deal and that's I have
to my audience my audience will go crazy
if I don't say something though about
Gavin Newsom because he to me is exactly
why I'm no longer a Democrat the reason
I literally fled California because of
him high taxes endless regulation
lockdowns keeping his Winery open like
so I'm I'm with you that you need a
diverse broad Coalition of people and
different ideas and all that stuff but
that guy I I just I would be remiss if I
did not say that but I love that because
I that's when I want to run I want to
have that discussion with him I want to
sit on a stage
and say exactly what you just said
because you know we should have thought
that working people involved in this
debate you know I want people who I
don't agree with
and I also want to say the show that we
can have a civil discussion with each
other even though
you know you know even though we have
these profound disagreements you know I
there's nobody who disagrees more with
the way the way that
um that Gavin uh Newsome ran uh the
covet operation and you know I was in
San Francisco this week and I spent
like I guess almost nine months in in
San Francisco during the Monsanto trials
so you know I I got to know the city
really well and loved the city
and the courthouse is near enough Union
Square and that I could walk down to
Union Square every morning
and you had you know Union Square for
people who don't know San Francisco it's
like the Fifth Avenue of San Francisco
it's where all these props you know
Armani and Nordstroms and Banana
Republic and GAP and
and all of these you know powerful
iconic American corporations so the
Showcase of American retail might is
right there you know Levi's and and uh
and all of these and it is it is Fifth
Avenue West
and I went out there three weeks ago at
every one of those shops is closed every
one of them and it you know these are
huge buildings and giant malls and
Retail and they're just closed
they're boarded up because they you know
they just let they let them
language during these lockdowns that
just destroyed the city there's a third
30 35 vacancy rate then there's no way
that they're you know I don't even
understand
any conception of how they can bring
that City back
you know you need somebody I don't know
you need some very very powerful dynamic
character who can come in and and
convince these retailers that you know
that the policies are going to change
and that they they can take a risk on
California on San Francisco again and
that's all Gavin Newsom
and I want to talk to them about that I
want to talk on a stage you know about
what do you think that's good for
America you know are you happy what are
you
yeah what do you make of the people that
now are refusing to talk to you because
look I'm with you I I would love for you
to have that conversation with Newsome I
I think he's he's I mean he destroyed
San Francisco as mayor as you're
pointing out and then he destroyed the
state in essence California as Governor
uh but you know it's not just him I mean
you know Jake Tapper went on CNN what
was it about 10 days ago and said he
would not have you on the show because
of your dangerous misinformation there
was obviously this famous thing with uh
Dr Peter Hotes on uh you know telling
Rogan that he'll no longer do the show
and he won't even he won't debate you by
the way I then had Brett Weinstein and
uh Jay bhattacharya offer to debate
hotels he won't debate them either but
this notion that you're out there saying
hey I'll talk to you guys and now
they've framed you as oh he's
Untouchable as if something you've said
is so crazy
yeah I mean if you can't debate it it's
not science what was you know the
Sciences is
rooted in reason and logic and um and
you know scientists are supposed to be
able to subject themselves you know to
the furnace of debate
and you know allow the you know the the
their ideas to Triumph in them and that
might become annealed and debate and
then to Triumph in rise in the
marketplace of ideas
and if you can't do that I mean they say
well because I'm a fraud
and a clack and a Charlotte and all the
other you know things that they say
about me that you know you can't debate
somebody like that but that's a bunch of
but first of all
you know I've I've won hundreds and
hundreds of cases by arguing in front of
juries
and you know with people who if I was
making these kind of you know absurd
claims that you know if I was the kind
of person that was making those kind of
claims that were baseless
uh that the other attorneys in those
cases would chew me up and spit me out
and humiliate me in front of the jury
because that's what we are trained to do
and so you know I I what does all the
truth one time with Rogan
is two or three years ago Rogan said why
don't you debate uh Bobby Kennedy
and he said well he's a cunning lawyer
and you know I'm not trained with debate
well
you know every scientist is is a you
look at what Darwin did and what you
know
and even like Archimedes and you know
all of the the Galileo and all these
they had to
defend their ideas I mean their forums
set up all over the world where
scientists get together and you know and
debate each other and those debates are
are vicious and they're uh and they're
oh for them very very high stakes debate
um and they're uh and they use every
trick but that's part of being a
scientist
s is you take your ideas and you and you
give them and you know the way that
what I would do with others I really
have a lot of domain knowledge about
vaccine uh studies I you know I've
written books about them I've assembled
them
um and so I would you know my my way of
debating would it be asking asking him
showing him the studies and saying you
know how can you explain this if what
you're saying is true show me your study
either way
I've had private debates with the hotels
so I probably spent I don't know 10 or
20 hours with him uh because a few years
ago
um somebody
asked me I somebody who I was with whom
I was very close
oh maybe they were going to come out
publicly against me with vaccination and
this person is very wired in it and I
age and I said before you do that
put me in a room with a guy who knows
more about vaccines than anybody in the
world
and you listen to me debate them and
then make up your mind about whether or
not you want to go public against me
and so he called Francis Collins
and Francis Collins and Tony fauci
and they didn't want to do it but then
he said the guy to do it is Peter Hotes
oh he is their you know their Champion
he's uh he's their Goliath
and so hot has got in a series of phone
calls with me and this other individual
and uh the let me just say this the
individual did not come out publicly
against me after listening to those
debates but we then had a lot of email
exchanges where I would say show me the
study that shows that vaccines don't
cause all that any of the vaccines given
the first six months of life don't give
uh don't cause autism
he ended up sending me 11 studies about
the MMR vaccine which is not does not
fit in that category and Institute of
medicine the National Academy of
Sciences those studies don't exist
I showed him those papers so I'm
you know his I don't think his fear is
that I would say something that was sort
of crazy and detached from reality I
think his fear is that I would expose
reality
right I mean that that's the point like
it's not like you're some random cook on
the street it's like if you were saying
crazy things he should be able uh to
debunk them let's hit a couple other uh
topics
um the affirmative action decision came
out a week or so ago from the Supreme
Court and you know I've been on board so
much of what you're saying even though
as I said I I'm I don't consider myself
a Democrat I moved to Florida it's the
first time I've ever registered as a
republican since I've been here in
Florida
um but I saw your your Tweet Thread
about the affirmative action decision
and basically you were you were against
the decision uh and I was hoping maybe
you could just walk us through the the
philosophy there yeah and I under
people
um you know a bit different about that
with me and a lot of the people who have
supported me on other issues
I would be disappointed by that but you
know that
um
and look listen I grew up in a state
um that was a Jim Croce day
oh when I grew up in Virginia I
um you know it was illegal at that time
for a black man to marry a white woman
uh every aspect of life was governed by
considerations of race
um you were identified by black on your
birth certificate
you were raised in a black neighborhood
you attended secret black segregated
schools you Transportation public parks
um everything every asthma you were you
were identified by race
on your death certificate and buried in
a black Cemetery I had a a guy it was a
guy who worked for for my family and I
from when I was young I was going
hunting and and trapping Hawks down in
the southern part of Virginia
and he would carry me on those trips
and he had been a World War II van he
was in the Seabees he was six foot five
incredibly smart and when we stopped in
restaurants I would have to go in and
buy the food and bring it out so that
the two of us could eat it in the car he
asked me one day to accompany him on a
I'm into the local shoe store because he
was not allowed in the shoe store he had
to I had to buy the shoes from bring
them out decide
and he had to try them on the curb oh
you know when I and my my family was you
know deeply involved in the civil rights
movement and I
and you know a lot of people look at
affirmative action say well you know
it's been a it's been a a hundred and
150 years since the Civil War
you know uh people have had black
Americans have had time to recover
um but you know I was uh you know I I
saw what it was like to be black when I
was a kid I saw that you know at all of
us
higher levels of society were forbidden
right you know in my lifetime
and my family was deeply involved in
ending that system of Jim Crow
and part of
um of you know of that process was doing
something that normally I wouldn't
believe in
which is uh which is allowing you know
uh
considerations of race
to uh
to affect the judgments about who gets
these you know positions in colleges
and I also know Dave
at almost all of those colleges already
have a system of preference
and the system of preferences for
legacies you know for people like me who
had a
grandfather who went to Harvard a father
went to Harvard and uncles that went
there and so I it's much easier for me
to get in
but all of those legacies and also the
the
um The Offspring of faculty
are given preferences if you look at a
pie chart or losing almost none of those
kids are black
so this is kind of a way of
counterbalancing that and it's not you
know believe me I have a lot of problems
with it too and let me tell you what the
problems are and I see it was
affirmative action is one it's just
contrary to American values that you
know
meritocracy it's an illusion though as I
said that we're meritocracy because
there are all these built-in biases and
preferences
and also I think that the bigger problem
is what Barack Obama calls
um uh you know the the subtle bigotry of
low expectations
um that you know people a black kid in a
college
in a good college that people are
looking at that kid and saying uh oh he
got in here because he got a preference
and I don't think that's good for
America either so I understand that that
you know I I think the Supreme Court has
made a decision that debate is now over
about affirmative action
we're moving on and we're gonna you know
try to preserve them on the beach had
that black Americans got during that
period in faculty positions in business
positions Etc
and but uh you know for me I would say
that we probably should have kept it in
place for a few more years but
um you know it's over now
right I I get the intentions just just
one more on that what what would you say
in that case to the kid the say 16 or 17
year old Asian kid who you know scored
perfect on his SATs and had all A's and
you know he knows he's not getting into
Harvard because someone with
significantly less grades is going to
get in no one gave that Asian kid
anything he might be second American
from South Korea and his parents owned a
bodega that was a lot of kids that I
grew up around I mean what do you say to
that kid I think that's what that's what
the Nugget really comes down to here
yeah I I agree with that I think that's
a it's a it's a um you know it's a it's
not an easy position on any side to take
but
um you know as far as that Asian kid
goes there's kids getting into that
college because they're good at sports
who don't have that kind of academic
um you know discipline or academic uh
performance record so there's all kinds
of biases that get certain people in and
um and you know and and it it's not
America it's not a straight meritocracy
there's no College there are very few
colleges in this country I'm not going
to say no
it's just look at your GPA
and you're you know and your test scores
and say that the top you know 3 000 kids
with the best test scores in the country
the kids are going to get into this
college they're all the decisions are uh
aren't ripping with bias of one kind or
another so
um and unfortunately the bias
you know these studies show that the
biases tend to reflect
the racial composition of the admissions
Department that you know people tend to
favor people who look like them
and give them a preference and you know
a lot of the emissions departments
didn't have black people in them and so
uh you know that's uh it's not an easy
question Dave it's not one that I will
you know I'm
I I it's one that's inconsistent with a
lot of my other values and ideas about
the country but you know because of my
background and
um and uh I you know I land on that side
yeah I think I think that's as Fair uh
or as honest an answer as you can give I
personally I happen to disagree but but
that's that's just fine that's the point
of all of this yeah
um let's hit a couple other things so so
Ukraine War uh there seems to have been
this odd flip amongst the parties when I
was growing up again as a democrat in
New York and my family we all considered
ourselves JFK Democrats Daniel Patrick
Moynihan Ed Koch probably many of the
the you know people that you literally
grew up around but that your your
ideological Heroes as well
um the Democrats were sort of the
anti-war party that was at least the
notion and it was the Republicans and
the neocons who then wanted to Nation
build and all of these things we seem to
have had a flip on that now I get there
are plenty of Republicans that are for
this Ukraine war as well but it does
seem to be being driven more by the
Democrat Party at least because Biden is
in office what do we do well first off I
guess do you think that's a fair uh
estimation and then what do we do about
this to get ourselves out of this before
World War III comes yeah and it's
getting to a crazy point right now where
we're now you know by an Administration
a year ago is that that uh when they
were called on to 10 cluster Palms to
Israel
by an Administration Jen basaki said use
the cluster problems was a war crime yep
yesterday President Biden announced that
they're sending cluster bombs to uh to
Russia and meanwhile they're telling the
American people that were winning the
war cluster moms are a last resort
weapon
and they're saying they have to send
them because they've run out of other
weapons so what is actually happening
why are we being lied to
clearly we're we're being lied to but
now
you have this split and and by the way
the driving force behind Wars in this
country have been a group of people
called the neocons that are embedded in
the state department from the top to the
bottom that's absolutely pervasive in
the state department
and uh but
um and they were you know a lot of them
were driven out because they after the
Iraq War they you know they published
their Manifesto in the late 1990s it was
called the project for a New American
Century and this outlined their plans
for the world and what they said is
that America had won the Cold War and as
the Victor it was uh it was be our
privilege
to run the world for an for at least a
century it would be the American Century
project for a New American Century
and that we should accomplish this feat
through the use of our Superior military
power and through violence
and it outlined eight countries that
needed to be overthrown including Iraq
and then shortly after that uh
publication of that the neocons and the
White House who surrounded President
George W bush
um you know defrauded us into the Iraq
War by saying there were weapons of mass
destruction and suggesting you know
falsely that that Saddam had something
to do with
the 9 11 attack now that work cost us in
the end about eight trillion dollars we
left Iraq worse than we found it we
killed more Iraqis than Saddam Hussein
the country is now an incoherent you
know battle between Shia and Sydney test
was
we push Iraq into a proxy posture with
Iran which is you know the exactly the
foreign policy outcome that we were
trying to avoid for 40 years
we created Isis
we drove 2 million refugees into Europe
which destabilized all the nations in
Europe for you know the next
uh probably a century I mean what's
happening in France with Iraq with the
riots today is a direct result of our
intervention in Iraq and Syria
brexit it was an outcome but it was
blowback from our intervention in Iraq
and Syria oh we broke apart Europe you
know and and all of those neocons were
driven out of office and we thought they
would have gone from government forever
um they were pariahs you know they were
in shame disgrace and
um
but
they reappeared first in the Obama
Administration a few of them
and then
now they run the uh the Biden
Administration Victoria Newland Tony
blinken these are you know key figures
in uh and uh in fact Victoria Newman's
husband Robert Kagan was the author of
project for a New American Century that
being an act document that I referred to
and they're the ones who have or you
know orchestrated this Ukraine or their
Vision was
um that we should they've always wanted
to dismantle and balkanize Russia
and run Russia and
um and be able to devour its natural
resources you know if U.S companies and
exploiting the oil Etc so they believe
that Russia was weak militarily and um
and that Putin was weak
they were mistaken
and they said they felt like if we
punish Russia with these Draconian
sanctions the economy would implode it
would destabilize the country they would
overthrow Putin and whoever replaced
Putin
no matter if they were more nationalists
more violent it wouldn't matter because
Putin himself was the guy that was
holding Russia together
and they had to get rid of him because
then it with the whole rush you know
Russian Enterprise would fall apart
and they you know they say in in
brzezinski's book Etc they say again and
again and again we got to draw Russia
into a war like we did in Afghanistan
and expose its military and its best to
run to a war against NATO and we can
deploy all of NATO forces against them
we can expose the weakness of the
Russian army in the Russian state it
will uh they'll they'll be a ousting of
Putin Etc this was their plan
oh
you know Putin did not want to go into
Ukraine we now know that's clear he
wanted to sign the Minsk Accords even
when dumbass and Lucas voted to leave
Ukraine he said no 90 they voted 90 to
10 to leave and he said no
you stay part of Ukraine but let's make
a deal to keep um to protect you from
you know from the violence
by the government that you know the U.S
installed in Ukraine in 2014.
and
um and let's uh keep NATO of the Ukraine
which was the existential threat that
they were most frightened about it the
U.S kept saying we're going to put uh
we're going to put NATO into Ukraine
we're going to violate all of our
promises not to do that
and and then we torpedo the minska
courts Lance agreed to it Germany agreed
to it Russia had agreed to it zielinski
ran
in 2019 saying that uh anyone 70 about a
comedian
wins with no political experience it's
like David you ran for president
promising peace and because God help us
all that you got elected and then you
change your mind right that's what
happened something changed his mind
clearly he was threatened with murder
uh by
um nationalist Ultra nationalists within
the Ukrainian government and
threatened with a cut off by Victoria
Newland the people you know the neocons
in the White House and the state
department so then what we now know is
then April of 2022 they signed a peace
agreement modeled on the men's Accords
Putin signed it and solinsky signed it
and the Russians were acting in good
faith by withdrawing all their their
forces from the Ukraine
what happens we send the White House
sends Boris Johnson over there to
torpede or that agreement so we wanted
this war and we wanted it for something
that had nothing to do with Ukraine well
now the neocons are getting cold feed
and there is division within the neocons
and Richard Haas is one of the oldest
neocons
is now saying you know by Administration
sending cluster bombs they're going to
try to let Ukraine into NATO what's
going to happen then
right then then we're bound
and all what what will really happen
Dave is this he we then have to then
NATO was that NATO is going to throw
Russia out of the Ukraine including
Crimea
Russia will never leave that it would be
like us being defeated with by Mexico
it's not going to happen you saw I mean
you remember what happened the the
Stalingrad the sacrifice the Russians
were willing to make during World War II
the Russians are unbeatable they what
they're killing ukrainians right now at
a seven to one ratio we've killed 350
000 Ukraine it's completely
unnecessarily
they're butchering we've turned that
country into an abattoir of death with a
flower of Ukrainian Youth and but now
if we let them into NATO
the defeat that they've that they've now
suffered now all of NATO is going to go
in there
but here's what really is going to
happen
many of the NATO countries are going to
refuse
Greece will never go to war against
Russia right it'll be us in essence what
and what it will do is it will expose
title V which is the agreement that
where they all have and with one of them
goes to where they all have to go to war
it will expose that as a paper tiger and
all of NATO then will fall apart so that
neocons in the White House are now
divided because some of them the smarter
ones
are terrified that this will be the end
of NATO and um and so they're now saying
you know they're now telling uh
President Biden you can't
let
um let Ukraine into NATO and um
and you know who knows what he's going
to do because
who knows how much
of these decision making is actually
taking place
in Joe Biden's brain
and how much of it is just being told to
him you know do this do that
and it's unclear because I would say I
would say it's probably very very little
in Joe Biden's brain so let me just
let's just follow up on that and then I
just have one more for you and then
we're we're good uh so what would you do
I mean how so now it's January 25. what
what are you doing on day one to make
sure that this thing does an escalate
peace with Putin
uh you know it's our or it's a proxy war
between the US and Russia and I'll
negotiate a peace
you know of course the ukrainians will
be part of that and you know but let's
negotiate a piece my poons wanted to
negotiate from the beginning we haven't
talked to the Russians
or at least six months why are we
talking to them every day
and by the way you know the new these
neocons like Richard Haas are secretly
talking to the Russian leadership
because they want to get out of there
now they understand that they made a
huge huge mistake
right you know put by our own we you
know we do polling over there the U.S
firms do polling and our government does
polling and those polls are showing an
extraordinary popularity but Putin is
now stronger than ever
you know he's got 90 popularity and
approval ratings among the Russian
people so you know they have not
weakened him they've strengthened him
and the and the you know the Russian
people are resolved and they are not
going to lose this war
I want to ask you just one other thing
because uh you know we've people have
heard you talk about some of the reasons
you like Trump and some of the reasons
you dislike Trump and obviously you've
laid out here some of your frustrations
with with Biden and the Democrat Party
but the one other guy that seems to be
in the mix here I don't know that I've
heard you talk about it all actually is
DeSantis he's a huge reason why I moved
my family and two companies here to
Florida and I see what the results of of
governing right are I see you guys sort
of lined up on covid I see you kind of
lined up on the agencies certainly on On
the Border I saw the video you did at
our uh you know the wall in Mexico just
watching hundreds of people from as you
said dozens of countries just walk right
through I'm wondering do you see any
touch points there or or and and what
maybe are the the chasms there that I'm
not seeing I thought what he did during
covet was really you know real
leadership
he um he broke with the the dominant
Theology and he did what he exactly what
a leader should do is he called he got
contacted
the best scientists in the world you
know the scientists from uh from
Stanford from Harvard from Oxford
he flew them into Florida and had them
sit down and say what actually should we
be doing and you know he has the right
questions and I think you know Florida I
ended up with a much better record than
any of the other states even though
Florida has
this population you know the most
vulnerable population because it has a
you know a lot of seniors
disproportionate number of seniors in
Florida and yet they still did a lot
better than you know a particularly
comparable States size States like
California
with many fewer seniors and so I thought
he did really well in that
um
I uh
you know I don't know I feel like some
of the um
the stuff that he's done since then have
kind of a mean side to it
um and uh which I don't I don't like
that it feels a little it feels like
bullying
but I don't know I mean I you know my my
I I've talked I've met with him twice
and both of our meetings were very very
um friendly and I um and I really really
like his wife Casey I think she's
fantastic
um and so you know
I I guess um
things to think about and more to be
seen
Robert I will leave you with this
because I say it on the show whenever we
play your clips that if the Democrats
will not put you on that debate stage I
don't know if it's too late but I have a
feeling that the Republicans would so
either way I I wish you a lot of luck
and I thank you for taking the time
thanks Dave thanks so much for having me
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell